The threat
that promises to have an impact of
on all of us,
not just politicians, not just
people are in the public eye.
Artificial intelligence,
the technology is moving so fast
it can baffle
even the people creating it.
Its potential impact
on everything
from national security to your job
as the head
of the industry
warning of the risk
of their own creations.
They're going so far as to ask Congress
to regulate them before it's too late.
My worst fears are that
we cause significant
we the field, the technology,
the industry caused significant
harm to the world.
We have built machines
that are like bulls in a china shop.
Powerful, reckless
and difficult to control.
But we think that I should be regulated
at the point of risk, essentially.
And that's the point
at which technology meets society.
Pick whatever movie analogy you'd like.
The Terminator,
Frankenstein, iRobot, The Matrix.
Basically any plot
where machines
outsmart and outpace human beings.
It is becoming a reality.
Science fiction
is actually turning into fact.
The discussion about A.I.
went down at a historic Senate
hearing today.
The panel looked at the benefits
and serious
risks of this advanced technology
like image manipulation
or election
disinformation that can potentially
sway voters.
There are A.I.
threats to democracy,
to the economy, to jobs,
to privacy,
social media, art, the justice system,
even war.
Lawmakers made very clear
they see the potential threat.
Senator Richard Blumenthal
actually kicked off the hearing
with a deepfake
recording of his own voice.
And now
for some introductory remarks.
Too often we have seen what happens
when technology outpaces regulation.
The unbridled
exploitation of personal data.
The proliferation of disinformation.
The remarks were written by Chad GBG
when it was asked how
I would open this hearing.
Joining me now is former
Google CEO and Chairman Eric Schmidt,
who is now an investor in an AI startup.
Is Tori is that how I say it?
Anthropic. Anthropic. My bad.
All right.
Okay, let's start here.
What are the risks?
We just saw a senator
using it for something that
it seems innocuous.
It's your own voice,
and it was something nice.
But what are the real risks here?
Well, first, 15
seconds on the extraordinary benefits
of AI.
An AI tutor, an AI doctor, helping
everyone get smarter
globally available, lifting
people from poverty, solving
climate change, accelerating
drug discovery.
My industry is crazy over this stuff.
The power and the innovation
that will occur
that's been unleashed in
this last round is phenomenal.
At the same time,
we're also very concerned
about potential risks
as these models get larger
and larger
means in terms of the scale of training.
$100 million of cost of training.
They take on properties
that are concerning the ability,
for example,
to change from one media to another,
such as voice
casting and things like that.
Imagine a situation
where you could ask it to do
cyber attacks.
It has learned how to do this
not because it was programed to do it,
because it encountered the information.
And what the industry does today
is it put guards,
it puts guardrails on these systems.
We're very concerned
that those guardrails
need to get set right
and they need to be applied everywhere.
All right.
Let me ask you about
the sort of potential of that,
because a lot of this
sounds like science fiction
to a lot of people.
When you start
thinking about the possibilities
and you named a lot of the good things
that could do languages,
it could probably,
you know, help
you pick up languages, translate,
translate, write all that.
But even if we
we don't get to these sort of science
fiction moments in history,
how much does this technology change?
The everyday landscape,
our work, our home, everything?
Well, some of my friends write documents
and they say, edit this.
They send the document
to GPT four in this case
and it produces a better version.
Right. That's an amplifier.
So in most cases, this technology
will make you quicker,
more efficient, smarter,
you know, better,
a better communicator,
whatever it is that you're doing,
that the same
will be true
for physicists and chemists
and teachers and poets and so forth.
That's all good.
The issue, of course,
is that the same evil person,
if they were evil,
gets an amplification
of their ability to spread evil.
A good example
here would be that in 2016,
the Russians used a series of people
to create fake identities
and flood the zone
right in 2016
to try to affect the election.
This has occurred over and over again
in other democracies.
We're going
to have one heck of a year in 2024
because today that too,
those tools are available
to a single, lone bad person
who can use that
to generate fake identities.
Fill an entire network
of false information that looks legit.
Right? Right.
That spreads through social media.
And off we go.
I do want to challenge
you a little bit on
just the idea of just an evil person.
Here's the thing
that a lot of people worry about
when I talk to just regular folks
who don't know a lot about A.I..
Insurance companies, businesses,
trying to use your information
against you
through a guy's brain, basically.
And that is a huge concern.
You talked about the guard wells
and you feel like
those need to be set in stone.
But social media companies
set rules, right?
If they're the ones that are like,
you set the rules,
you know how this works.
That didn't work so well
with social media.
That didn't work so well.
And the government comes in
and they're behind the eight ball.
They're not sure how the technology
works themselves.
And it's already taken off
and created a myriad of problems.
Well, social media is largely
not regulated.
That's right.
And you see the consequence,
and I think most of us believe
that we missed that opportunity.
Some of the senators
today in the hearing said the same thing.
There's an agreement,
I think, between the industry
and the government
that we don't want to repeat
some of those mistakes,
but we want to get the good stuff.
And what you're seeing now in the U.S.
government
is they're beginning to think about it.
This is a good process.
It's not obvious
exactly how the regulatory
regulations will come.
I have my own proposal. Sam has his.
Other people have different ideas.
This technology will be regulated
in some way
because of its potential dangers.
Just don't regulated out of existence,
in which case we won't get the benefits.
Can I just ask you lastly,
when it comes to war,
because we talked about the fact
that it can be used
in war,
is it more dangerous
then, for example, or nuclear war,
the way we think of conventional war,
the worst case scenario?
Well, nuclear war is horrific.
And any sort of large
nuclear conflagration
would destroy the world as we know it.
You can imagine this technology,
for example,
active cyber
attacks, attack a whole country.
Do it until everybody's dead.
And you can imagine that scenario.
You can also imagine the scenario
where you say,
I want to kill a million people.
Show me a biological path to do it.
These are the dangers
that we have to make
sure are not happening.
We need to put guardrails and limits.
People are working on these problems.
We don't fully understand
the solutions yet.
Eric Schmidt, you just terrified me.
I hear the good things, but boy,
that is a really scary scenario.
Thank you so much for coming on
and being candid
about the good, bad and ugly of a I.